a ver el poder de ortega y de su esposa
la señora murillo es hoy día en
nicaragua y desde hace ya un tiempo
total ellos controlan el congreso
controlan el poder judicial el
ministerio público la policía y el
ejército que están dispuestos a usar ese
poder a pesar del escándalo que genera a
nivel nacional y a nivel internacional
el objetivo es limpiar la cancha y
presentarse finalmente a unas elecciones
presidenciales el 7 de noviembre sin que
exista un competidor que sea capaz de
derrotar a ortega es principalmente el
objetivo y aunque parezca esto
absolutamente
grotesco algo aquí a lo que no estábamos
acostumbrados la américa latina y eso es
lo que está haciendo gradual y
sistemáticamente uno a uno todos los
días y detienen a alguien importante de
la sociedad civil con el propósito de
generar el terror y en el resto de la
población y entender cuáles son las
reglas del cuerpo el 15 de junio la oea
aprobó la resolución con la que condenó
los arrestos y los acosos que tan
efectivo puede ser este texto para
generar presión internacional frente a
lo que ocurre en el país además una
resolución que no todos los países
firmaron
mira esa resolución es importante no
sólo por el texto que exige la
liberación inmediata de todos aquellos
que han sido detenidos condena estos
hechos sino también por el número de
países que la prueba de 26 países de la
región es un número importante es un
número alto lamentablemente argentina y
méjico se abstuvieron y firmaron un
documento alternativo que caen en
enormes contradicciones es realmente un
retroceso habla de la no injerencia a
los asuntos internos y sugiere que hay
instituciones democráticas a las que hay
que respetar en nicaragua lo cual es
absolutamente falso es importante este
pronunciamiento por sí solo no va a
cambiar las cosas pero es un primer paso
especialmente si el objetivo es por
ejemplo lograr que naciones unida se
ocupe de esta situación y que el
secretario general de naciones unidas
tome cartas en el asunto para eso es
importante que exista una mayoría
regional que condena estos hechos en
naciones unidas ese pronunciamiento
regional
tiene el peso señor vivanco los
familiares de los llamados presos
políticos denunciaron violencia excesiva
por parte de los agentes y en ocasiones
han asegurado que no poseen orden
judicial para allanar las casas de los
detenidos además de esposarlos y
golpearlos qué instancia debería evitar
que estos hechos irregulares ocurran
cuando el gobierno está a favor de las
detenciones
no hay ninguna instancia a nivel
nacional en nicaragua que pueda evitar
estos hechos los abusos las torturas los
tratos crueles y la falta total del
debido proceso imagínate que cristiana
chamorro está secuestrada en su propio
hogar no le dejan salir de su propio
cuarto el resto de la casa está invadida
por agentes armados no tiene acceso a su
abogado
apenas se puede comunicar con un
familiar que lo visita que la visita el
resto de los detenidos están en 50
circunstancias similares es decir acá no
hay debido proceso' acá se han inventado
procedimientos judiciales única
únicamente con el propósito de
amedrentarlos
y detener los secuestran los
lamentablemente desgraciadamente no hay
esta gente está en total
como ya dije indefensión en desamparo si
no hay una reacción internacional fuerte
mucho más fuerte de lo que hasta ahora
hemos podido presenciar esto va a
continuar pues los capturados han sido
acusados de actuar contra el gobierno al
incitar a la injerencia extranjera y las
detenciones se dan de cara a las
elecciones de noviembre donde ortega
busca una nueva reelección con este
panorama como se logran las garantías de
justicia y transparencia que se piden
para los comicios
no hay posibilidades de celebrar
comicios transparentes mínimamente
creíbles de las actuales condiciones y
esto es realmente una burla acá se están
violando normas elementales no sólo
respecto a lo que es derechos humanos
sino también normas y principios básicos
de una democracia representativa de
principios que están consagrados en la
carta democrática
ortega está abiertamente violando estas
estas normas estos principios y
realmente digamos estos procedimientos
no tienen ninguna legitimidad lo único
que cabe la condena y la presión
internacional señor vivanco pues muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
acompañarnos estamos muy pendientes de
lo que pueda ocurrir en nicaragua